did you know document AI custom
extractor is now powered by generative
AI with custom extractor you can create
a document parser in a matter of minutes
to extract Fields there's no need to
train or label a new model automate
tedious tasks improve data extraction
gain deeper insights from unstructured
and structured document information as a
result you can realize faster time to
Value higher accuracy better
decision-making with no training
necessary simply Define the fields you'd
like to extract from structured or
unstructured documents and begin
processing you can achieve higher
accuracy by providing as few as 10
documents to fine-tune the generative AI
model all with a simple click of a
button or an API call get started today